[Music]
hi
my name is abby carey and i'm a
developer advocate for google cloud
devtools
and i'll be talking about maximizing
developer productivity with cloud code
so what are some development challenges
developers can face
one would be repetitive context
switching
you might find yourself bouncing between
a quick start guide three documentation
sets your code editor
and your terminal and your debugger just
get your project up and going and
testing it out
then there's getting started with gcp
which can be intimidating
you don't know where to start and get
overwhelmed by the docs we throw out at
you which is quite a bit
quite a bit of docks there's a lot of
content the products we support can also
be complex
a big one being kubernetes and
quite a few of our products require yaml
configuration files you probably don't
like
dealing with yaml you want to focus on
your code not configurations
so these issues i mentioned usually
happen in the inner loop seen on the
left here
you're probably familiar with this
process uh this is your day to day
as a dev you code up a feature build it
test it find a bug and then rinse and
repeat over and over again until your
feature is looking good
and you're ready to get into the outer
loop and then ship it out to the world
but how can we make these development
challenges a bit better
and improve your productivity well
that's where cloud code comes in
cloud code is an ide plugin that
automates development workflows for
cloud native applications
this plugin is composed of a bunch of
tools that can assist you in a variety
of workflows for gcp
it integrates these tools right into the
ui of your ide
and these tools automate repetitive
processes seen in your inner loop
overall it's here to save you time and
make you more productive
and looking back this picture again
cloud code is all about focusing on the
left hand side here
so who can use cloud code if you're
developing in java python go or node.js
chances are we got you covered we
support pycharm intellij golan and
webstorm from jetbrains
as well as the popular visual studio
code and more recently
cloud shell editor which allows you to
use cloud code
in your browser so what are cloud code's
features at a glance
first of all it lets you build push and
deploy services to kubernetes and cloud
run
it has a simple ui so it's easy to rinse
and repeat
it also allows you to debug kubernetes
and cloud run services with the same ui
of your ide
that you're used to all you gotta do is
place a break point and then hit go
and you're debugging your kubernetes or
cloud run services
it also handles complex texts like port
forwarding for you
then there's our watch mode feature this
triggers rebuilds and redeploys when
code changes happen
all you gotta do is code up your change
hit save and then it triggers that
rebuild and redeplay
speeding up your development time
overall then
there's cloud code's most popular
feature which is yaml authoring
assistance
you get yaml snippets linting syntax
highlighting and on-hover docs for over
400 resource types
and finally there's easy api
discoverability with the ability to
quickly enable and get documentation
that you need
right from your ide
so what products does cloud code support
we support every product in a way
because cloud code has uh that
an api explorer where you can enable and
get the docs for
all of gcp's apis we also have
yamo authoring support for the big ones
like cloud build and kubernetes and we
have ui integration for three gcp
products including gke cloud run and
secret manager which means we give them
their own dedicated uh
panels within your ide
so focusing on cloud code's cloud run
features cloud code helps you ramp up
fast
on cloud run with integrated samples
that show best practices
you can also locally develop an emulated
cloud run environment which has to click
and viewer logs this is great for
catching issues in production
in a production like environment before
it actually has to go to production
and once that's ready and looking good
you can deploy to cloud run with just a
couple clicks
and finally view your services and their
properties
all from your ide but uh let's look at
this in a demo
all right so this is visual studio code
with cloud code already installed from
the ide marketplace and you can tell
because of the left we have a stack of
four icons
corresponding to the big workflows for
cloud run and kubernetes etc
down below we have the cloud code status
bar and when i click it i can create a
new application
i can pick between kubernetes cloudron
or a custom application
but today i'll use a cloud run
application
and we get a variety of languages to
pick from for our starter app but i'll
pick a flask python example
and clone it so this is our sample ready
to go
there's a docker file included so it's
ready to be containerized
i also have a requirements.txt file for
any packages i need
uh yeah so let's run this in the cloud
run emulator i want to test this out
locally before deploying to the cloud
the cloud run emulator as i said earlier
it's a production environment to test
out my service
i'll go ahead and click cloud code's
dashboard button and then
run on cloud run emulator
and then from here i can configure my
service including
container properties um i will set
dedicated cpus to
one virtual cpu to better emulate
running on cloud run
and then i can also switch the
environment variable tabs and specify
environment variables for my service
and cloud sql connections if i'm
connecting to a cloud sql database
down below i can pick build settings i
will be building with docker
but i could also build with build packs
if i wanted to
and then there's also advanced build
settings if i pop
open this section here where you can
specify build arguments
and then there's this check box down
here for automatically
rebuilding and re-running on changes so
this is that watch mode i mentioned
and i'll leave it on because i want to
show you the iterative development
so right now we are building
and then we will be deploying but let's
check out the detailed view here i can
see everything going on behind the
scenes
and then i will switch back to the
normal view
and we have a we can see that the
service has been deployed to localhost
but instead of clicking that url i could
also click the cloud code status bar
button
and from here i can turn off watch mode
open my deployment logs or
open the service url i'll open the
service url
and here is my service running in the
cloud run emulator
but what if i want to test out iterative
development i want to change this
it's running string to something else so
i'll minimize this for the moment
and then i'll open up app.pi and i will
find that string and then update it to
something like this is my
service yeah that looks good and i'll
hit save
and that will trigger a rebuild as you
can see happening below
and then finally a redeploy
and we've got that service url so i'll
go ahead and refresh my service
and this is my service that string just
updated
that was look at it of development with
cloud code
so i'll go ahead and close that out and
stop this
but now i want to test out debugging all
i got to do
i'll place a little breakpoint like
right here on line 16 go to the debugger
pane and hit play
and i sped this up a little bit here but
we've specified where we want to debug
and i will go ahead and open this up and
when i open up my service it's kicked
off debugging
and now i will just step through the
code a little bit here
so you can see what happens you know you
can see the
variables coming up here my message is
this is my service i got my service name
you can also see stuff going on in the
call stack
and i will play to finish that up and
disconnect the debugger
so this is looking great and now i want
to deploy it to cloud run
so i'll go ahead and open up the cloud
run explorer
and here you can see i already have my
project set and i have four existing
cloud run services
but what if i want to deploy a new one
so
up above there is a little cloud button
here and this will allow me to deploy to
cloud run
i could also deploy it from the cloud
code status bar but we'll go this way
so i have the option to create a new
service or deploy revision to an
existing service but i will create a new
one and then going down
i can select my deployment platform i'll
be going to
cloud run fully managed but we also
support cloud run for anthos
going down more i will allow
unauthenticated invocations of this
cloud run service
i can specify a service account if i
want and you'll see those advanced
settings that you saw when i was setting
up the
cloud run emulator for local testing
including environment variables and
called sql connections
and this time i'm going to for build
settings i'm going to switch
from docker to build packs
just because i can so this is if you
didn't have a docker file we could use a
build pack and i've sped this up a
little bit but we are building and
deploying
and in the cloud run explorer you will
see hello world one pop
up yep so our service has deployed and
we're giving a little url to the right
here and i will open that up and this
is our cloud run service running in the
cloud on cloud run
so back to the cloud run explorer i can
open up this hello world
service here and i can see my existing
revisions
i only have one right now so 100 of my
traffic's going there
if i open that up i can see the
properties of my revision including how
much traffic's coming to
it it's container port and cpu
allocation
and if i close that and i can right
click my service
and easily get the url of where it's
deployed to
and i can deploy a new revision with
this little cloud code button
or view my logs with this button here
so that was a look at cloud codes cloud
run support and i encourage you to
download cloud code and give it a try
and join our slack community if you have
any feature requests
or questions about cloud code